[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: I want to
introduce Tim Larkin,
and I hope you guys enjoy it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM LARKIN: So when you look
at this subject, I mean,
I really appreciate
you guys showing up
for it, because most
people don't even
want to look at the subject.
You know, violence means a lot
of different things to people.
And it's a very specific
word that I used,
and I had to fight my publisher
to put it in the title.
Because oftentimes,
we misunderstand
when the appropriate time
would ever be to use violence.
The tagline that I normally
have in my training is violence
is rarely the answer.
But when it is, it's
the only answer.
And the interesting
part of that is
most people don't understand
when it is the answer.
They
So that's the whole premise
for writing the book,
because the subject
of violence has
been so stigmatized
in the last 50 years
that we don't even look at it.
We think there's no
good information when
you look at violence.
And therefore, the only
people that have availability
to the tool are the predators.
And my goal is to educate
people on the tool of violence.
And today specifically,
I want to take you
into some uncomfortable areas.
The best information,
when it comes
to your own
self-protection, really
comes from the worst
parts of society.
And we're going explore how to
look at something that we would
think we would have to dismiss,
and where we can actually
extrapolate really
good information
from these individuals.
But I think what we have
to do is we have to--
let me just see
what we've got here.
So the presentation will be
the Alpha Predators Speak.
And so we're going to hear
from people within the prison
system.
But before we do that, I want
you to understand the reason we
look at it is because they
live in this petri dish
of asocial violence.
Asocial violence is
imminent violence.
There's no communication.
There's no back and forth.
This is, you're facing
grievous bodily harm.
If you don't take
action, you're basically
going to be participating in
your own murder at that point.
And that's the
definition, that's
the threshold of when you
as sane, socialized citizens
would ever use the tool of
violence to protect yourself.
It's when you're
devoid of choice.
You know, if you have to
ask yourself whether or not
it's time to use violence, then
it's absolutely not the time.
And that's probably
the hardest thing
for people to wrap
their heads around.
They don't want
to imagine a time
when they have to use violence.
And that's something that the
people within the prison system
really understand, because
the only way they can survive
is if they're successfully
using violence.
It's their currency.
These prison gangs
derive all their power
from the successful use
of the tool of violence.
And because it's
derived from that,
they have to be very
results-oriented.
They have to look
at the individual,
and they have to look
at the human body,
and they have to sit
there and say, what works
and what doesn't work?
They don't care about
opinion, you know?
They don't care about whether
or not they like combat sport Y
or combat sport G.
It doesn't matter.
What matters is, did
you get a result?
And we'll talk more about why
they look at things that way.
Actually, let's go ahead.
I just want to say from
your own self-protection
that I want to start
out with a video.
Can we go ahead and start
out with this video?
I want you to watch this video.
We're going to go ahead
and start playing it.
This is an armed robbery.
Actually, can you show
it from the beginning?
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]?
TIM LARKIN: Yeah, show it
slow from the beginning.
Show the first time.
And then as soon as
they jump on the guy,
you can fast forward to the--
This is just an
armed robbery that
happened in Seattle on a bus.
And you can see the guy in
the background just walking
calmly, robbing people.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[YELLING]
- Drop your gun!
- Drop the gun!
TIM LARKIN: OK.
Go ahead and fast forward
it to the slow motion.
So now I want you to
watch the event again.
I think they do it two
more times in slow motion
where you see the gun
actually on the individual.
OK, that's good.
[END PLAYBACK]
What did you notice about that--
AUDIENCE: No one--
TIM LARKIN:
--watching that event?
Nobody-- yeah, exactly.
No interaction amongst anybody,
even though three people
were robbed prior
to that individual
getting the gun put on him.
Notice anything else?
AUDIENCE: He was completely--
he was completely oblivious
to his surroundings.
TIM LARKIN: Oblivious
Yeah.
Situational awareness was gone.
AUDIENCE: When he went--
when the potential victim
went to diffuse the situation,
he was pretty smart
to angle the gun down
and toward the assailant so
that he wouldn't have the option
to use it.
TIM LARKIN: Yeah,
he did a great job
of redirecting the vector
that you're talking about,
and he did a good job there.
Did you notice anything else?
AUDIENCE: He had time to put
his reading book in the pocket
or something.
Whatever he was doing.
He had something in
his hand, and then he
had time to [INAUDIBLE].
TIM LARKIN: These
things have hijacked us.
Look at this.
That individual had
a gun put on him.
He redirected the vector.
He actually did some good stuff.
He penetrated.
He went in.
A lot of things were
actually good there.
He had this in his hand.
And if you watch that again,
the reason I love showing
this is because
literally, he is--
and he can't get it right
into his pocket right away.
He's literally--
[LAUGHTER]
--a gun is on him, his
life is on the line,
and he wants to make sure
this damn thing doesn't drop,
instead of using it as
a bludgeoning device.
I just want you
guys to understand
how much these
things have hijacked
our situational awareness.
This is the number one
thing just to be aware of.
No there's nothing
we can do about it.
Yeah, now that
you see it, it is.
It's comical.
AUDIENCE: Why isn't he
using it from the beginning?
TIM LARKIN: Yeah, you'd
think he would use it,
but watch this again.
So this is-- OK, awareness now.
So now, good.
He gets up and he keeps
penetrating forward.
Not bad.
You think he's about to
use that to strike the guy.
And look.
Look how many times it takes
him to get it in the pocket.
Don't underestimate, you know?
The reason I come here today,
we live in this amazing world
of technology.
You guys are at the
absolutely tip of the spear
being at Google, OK?
And so it's amazing
to live in this.
My job, though, as I see
is to remind everybody
that we still live in
this physical world,
and that your world can be
turned upside down in seconds
if you just don't have basic
situational awareness on that.
I mean, if I had
told you a story
that a guy had a gun on him,
and that he redirected it,
and that he was more concerned
in putting it in his pocket,
you would have
thought I was crazy.
I have to show you that visual,
because it makes no sense.
Now that goes into an area
that probably most of you
have not looked at, which
is the prison gangs.
And the reason I like to
look at the prison gangs
is because these guys
live in a world that
is completely asocial
in violence, meaning
they have to understand how
to use the tool of violence
to be successful
in what they do.
But the way they look
at it is very strategic.
And also, we make
these assumptions
that prison is a very chaotic
environment, that these prison
gangs are just chaos and
the violence is random.
And nothing in my studies could
be further from the truth.
I got to consult with a
lot of top corrections
individuals that literally talk
to Aryan Brotherhood, Black
Guerrilla Family, Mexican Mafia.
And these are two videos that
I can share with you that talk
to these shock collars.
One is from the
Aryan Brotherhood,
and the other one is
from the Mexican Mafia.
And I'm going to play
the videos and just
let them speak so you
hear them, and then I'm
going to tell you why what
they said is relevant to us
and what we can learn
out of that, OK?
So let's go ahead with the
Aryan Brotherhood first.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- 27.
- This is the most notorious
inmate you've never heard of.
But behind bars,
he's a living legend.
By his own count, he's killed
22 men inside prison, all
during gang-related conflicts.
- I'm probably one of the
most violent individuals
you'll ever meet in your life.
No brag.
Just fact.
It's that simple.
- As a veteran of
numerous gang wars,
he's built a reputation as a
lethal prison yard combatant.
- I'm not the kind of man that
you want to underestimate.
The fact that I'm still
alive proves that.
- His name is Michael Thompson.
As a leader of the
Aryan Brotherhood,
he's been a key figure in the
gang's bloody rise to power.
- We've had the same
blood on our hands.
Intimacy comes in many,
many different forms.
Few things are as
intimate as murder.
Most people don't
understand that.
It's not a social club.
It's not a bunch of kids
playing at neo-Nazis.
These are very,
very dangerous men
who will exterminate your family
[SNAPS FINGERS] like that.
- The Brotherhood's
strategy is simple.
Be more extreme, more violent,
more terrifying than everyone
around you.
- Inmates will always fear
me more than they will staff,
because they believe that I
will kill them if they don't
do what I tell them to do.
That's the essence of power.
- The Brotherhood
encouraged Michael Thompson
to study anatomy texts, hunting
for the most efficient ways
to kill.
- Killing is not
something to take lightly.
It's not something
that I'm proud of.
But it's a reality.
It's a reality based on this
environment, and it's brutal.
There's nothing more brutal.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIM LARKIN: So the
Aryan Brotherhood,
through the successful use
of violence, represents--
I believe it is one half of
1% of the prison population.
And yet they absolutely
controlled prisons for years.
For a while, they were taken
out with some legal action,
but they're back up, strong
as they've ever been.
And the reason they
were able to do that
is because they were
so good at violence.
As a matter of fact, when the
Mafia Don John Gotti years ago
was incarcerated,
they had to do a deal
with the Aryan Brotherhood
in order to protect him.
The Italian mob couldn't
protect him in prison.
What's interesting
is through this,
they're able to control,
just like the Mexican Mafia,
they're able to control
everything on the streets.
Now understand,
these individuals,
both these individuals that
you're going to see here spent
a majority of their time when
they were leaders in a gang--
they both have defected--
when they were in.
They were incarcerated
23 hours out of 24 days.
They had little to no technology
available to them, yet they
ran organizations that literally
ran billions worth of dollars,
tens of thousands
of distributors,
and they controlled it all
with just basically, you know,
very low, low-tech means.
So from an
entrepreneurial standpoint
when I talk to
entrepreneurial groups,
it's really interesting.
You know, the excuse of, I
don't have the latest app
or I don't have the latest this
to do my job kind of goes out
the window when you
see how creative some
of these individuals
are, because they
run their organizations,
their vetting processes
and everything are similar, very
similar to any high-end vetting
process that you'd see
in any corporation.
So it's pretty amazing.
When you look at
them, you would think
there'd be no similarities.
There's huge similarities
between how these organizations
are run successfully.
The difference is the currency.
You know, where here, we
look at economic currency.
We look at market share.
We look at cash flow.
We look at the ability
to pull from that.
Technology.
These guys, it's all derived
through their successful use
of the tool of violence.
The next individual you're going
to hear from is Rene Enriquez.
He was called the Boxer.
He was one of the main shock
collars in the Mexican Mafia.
He is going to talk about
the education process, when
they educate somebody.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This is the most
notorious inmate you've--
[END PLAYBACK]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The Mexican Mafia
was created in 1956
at the Deuel
Vocational Institution
in Tracy, California.
Its founder was Luis
Huero Buff Flores.
Huero Buff's concept
was to create
the gangs of gangs, a
group of super killers
that would go on to control
California State Prison
inmates.
It's based on violence.
It's based on terror.
Its whole philosophy
is the utilization
of violence and terror to
achieve its objectives.
California's kind of like a pie.
Once a crew understands
that a territory's
claimed by [INAUDIBLE],,
they will not
encroach upon that territory.
To do so is punishable by death.
The Mexican Mafia does
not deal with individuals
it believes to be sources.
It kills them.
If you rat, you die.
If you cooperate, you die.
If you are a source, you die.
There is no exception to this.
Murder is the solution to most
problems in the Mexican Mafia.
It is effective.
Violence is a language
that we have perfected.
We kill our problems.
Violence and murder is
our conflict resolution.
The black hand is about death.
The Mexican Mafia is death.
This is a modern-day murder inc.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIM LARKIN: I gave
you these pictures.
This is when--
his arrest photos.
Because the guy
you're about to see,
you're going to think he's
a Fortune 100 CEO the way
he talks, except
for the neck tattoo.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Education has always been a
proponent in the Mexican Mafia.
It has always been understood
that education is power.
We immerse ourselves in
literature, correspondence
courses, reading, writing.
Mexican Mafia members
don't know limitations.
[INAUDIBLE] opportunity, and
they do that through education.
They understand that without an
education, they have no future.
It is the visionaries,
the progressive thinkers,
the individuals who
have strong intellect
that become the leaders
of the Mexican Mafia.
There is a station
for individuals
in the organization
who have no education,
and they are the monosylabbic
knuckle draggers.
We call them the no accounts.
These are individuals who
have stationed organizations
at the lowest rungs
of our hierarchy.
For the individuals
who become educated,
they float to the top.
They become our elite,
our de facto leadership,
the creme de la
creme, if you will.
Once it's understood that
a carnal is educated,
possesses strong
social political skills
and an advanced business
acumen through a series
of violent acts, which is
our status mobility system,
this coupled with his
intellect launches him
to a position of carnal de
palabra or a brother of word.
This is not an official
rank in the organization,
but it's inherently
understood by the membership
that this individual is a
force to be reckoned with.
He is a leader among leaders.
Some of the literature utilized
by [INAUDIBLE] Mexican Mafia
members is "The Art
of War" by Sun Tzu.
This gives us a view into
psychological warfare.
The 48 laws of power,
which is self-explanatory,
Machiavelli's "The
Prince," which
affords us an in-depth
view into politics
and utilizing humans
to achieve our goals.
Abnormal psychology
and general psychology
so that we can understand
human behavior.
Anatomy, which teaches
us how to kill.
Violence is our language.
We have to know how to kill.
We do this, this
acquisition of knowledge
is to further our
ability to be leaders,
to enhance the overall
objective of the organization.
This is not casual
reading for us.
This is our discipline.
Mexican Mafia members understand
that knowledge is power.
And with this power, we
can generate finances.
And through finances, we extend
the reach of the organization.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIM LARKIN: OK, so the
reason I shared this to you,
you might be thinking, wow.
That's intense.
It is intense.
And these individuals are there.
But what I wanted you to
see was the similarities.
When they got to the idea
of talking about violence,
there were two
similarities that you saw.
One was anatomy.
Anatomy across the board was
something that they studied.
And the reason is
anatomy ends up
being the Rosetta Stone
for self-protection.
And they understand this.
And the reason it's worth
looking at these individuals
is they can't afford
to be wrong when
they use the tool of violence.
And so good information comes
from horrible parts of society,
but it doesn't mean that
there's not good information.
Our own self-protection has
kind of been outsourced.
We've really, in
the last 50 years,
stopped kind of being our
own first responders, stopped
learning about physically
protecting ourselves.
We've got away from that.
And the downside of
that is it's rare
that I get to do
talks like this.
People normally see
me after the fact.
70% of the people that
come and train with me
are people much
like yourselves that
live in great neighborhoods,
have great lives,
all the right friends,
they never probably
experience violence, and
then in seconds, their lives
were turned upside down.
And they come to me.
And I can't undo that.
I can't undo what
happened to them.
I can give them
things to make sure
that it doesn't happen
more in the future to them.
I can give them skill sets that
will allow them to understand
what happened to them.
But what I really
try to do is I like
to reach to that 30% that
proactively comes and seeks out
self-protection training.
Just by attending
this talk, you've
proactively started to
look at this information.
And that's a huge first step.
The other thing is we tend
to make these individuals
into super humans.
We think there's something
special about them.
Yet the best people in the
world using their hands
and improvised tools
to kill other humans--
they reside in these systems--
have zero training in combat
sports and martial arts.
So it's not necessarily
about the training.
It's about knowledge
and it's about intent.
What's hard for us
as a society is we
have to decide when it would
ever be appropriate for us
to use the tool of violence.
And I call it a tool,
because it is a tool.
And the way you have to
understand that is let's
imagine a scenario of a mother
who is in her house at night.
Her husband has gone
on a business trip.
She just put her
infant son to bed.
She's cleaning up
in the kitchen,
getting ready for the next day.
And all of the sudden
through the back door, guy
comes crashing through
and attacks her.
He's trying to assault her.
Has her up against the railing.
And you know, she realizes
he's bigger, he's faster,
he's stronger.
She's going to try
to do something.
She flails around and she just
scratches his face really hard.
She just rips down the skin.
It enrages him.
He then looks over and he
sees the butcher's block,
and he grabs that knife
out of the butcher's block
and he plunges it
inside of her neck.
Her eyes roll up.
It's over in seconds.
Let's imagine the
same scenario again.
This time he comes
crashing through this way.
She gets thrown up
against the railing again.
She realizes he's bigger,
he's faster, he's stronger.
There's nothing she can do.
But this time, she's the one
that sees the butcher's block.
She grabs the knife.
She plunges it into
the side of his neck.
His eyes roll up.
It's over in seconds.
Now in the first
scenario, we would
say that individual, because of
what he did to a young mother,
deserves to be prosecuted
to the full extent of law.
He probably should be
incarcerated, at a minimum,
for the rest of his life.
If there's a death penalty
in that municipality,
he probably deserves it.
In the second scenario
with the mother, we say,
she should be held up
as a standard to society
that she not only protected
herself but her young infant
son.
She should face no
prosecution of the law.
If anything, she should be
held up as a model citizen
for protecting yourself,
as horrible as it was.
What I want you to
understand in this talk
was the knife to the side of
the neck worked both times.
It didn't care if
it was the good guy
or it was the bad guy
using the information.
Violence is merely a tool.
How the tool is used will be
determined, whether or not
it's a justified use
of the tool or if it's
a criminal use of the tool.
But the act itself is violence.
It is not self-protection.
It is not self-defense.
That is determined
after the act.
That's where everybody
gets it wrong.
Everybody thinks violence
is something separate.
Violence is what is used
in all of these scenarios,
and we need to understand
how the tool of violence
most effectively works.
And what you find when you
look at individuals like this
and you look at the people
that are the most successful
in using this is the biggest
flip that you need to make
is to get away from the idea
of bigger, faster, stronger,
because that's what we all use.
We look at somebody who's
bigger, faster, stronger,
and we say, there's
nothing I can do.
And what's most
interesting is when
you talk to these individuals
and the way they look at things
is they don't see
differences in human beings.
What they do is they all
focus on the similarities.
They might see somebody who
is physically bigger, faster,
and stronger than them,
and they'll look at them,
and they'll say, OK.
He has a throat like me.
He has knees like me.
He has a groin like me.
He has a lower margin
of the ribcage like me.
And that's how they
look at people.
And through that access,
they're giving their brain
really good
information that says,
I'm going to access all the
similarities in a human being,
and I'm to go after those which
are going to get me a result.
And they also understand
that injury to the human body
is universal in all of us.
We all have these
areas of the human body
that are susceptible to injury.
And the best place to get data
for that is sports injury data.
And the reason you
want to look at sports
injury data is
because that's humans
colliding with humans and humans
colliding with the planet.
And those are forces that
you and I can replicate.
So we can take away a lot of
the objections that most of us
have to training for our own
physical self-protection.
I have had probably some
of the most unlikely people
in the last 25 years
of me doing this
that have been able to use
very base information of injury
to the human body to save
themselves against bigger,
faster, stronger individuals.
Had a 52-year-old dentist
that walked in on a Sunday
to his clinic,
saw that a druggie
was busting into
his little infirmary
to grab some of the drugs there.
Saw the doctor.
Doctor realized, oh, man.
I don't have an escape.
Where he was, there's no
door or anything for him.
Realized that it was
an imminent situation.
This guy starts
fumbling, looking
like he's going to try to grab
what turned out to be a knife.
And this individual
realized, this is asocial.
There's no
communication going on.
This individual just
wants to harm me.
Charged the individual,
and this guy charged him.
Hit him to the side of the
neck, grabbed his head.
This is the doctor.
Grabbed his head, was at
the door jamb, and said,
oh, that door jamb's hard.
Hit him twice in the
head with the door jam,
and the guy dropped
to the ground
where he thought he might have
to stomp on him because he
thought maybe the
individual still
had the ability to attack him.
Realized the guy
was nonfunctional,
realized it was over, was
able to call the police.
And you know, affect the arrest.
What was interesting was the
police said to him after, they
said, you would
have been justified
in killing this individual.
His rap sheet is--
why didn't you?
And he was able to
say, I recognized
he was no longer a threat.
And that's because he understood
injury to the human body.
Now this is an individual that
went 52 years in his life--
I don't understand
this, because I grew up
with brothers-- he never
had any physical encounter.
His first physical encounter
after understanding
just this basic concept
that I'm talking about,
he was able to physically
protect himself.
So this is not competition.
You know, don't think of
your own self-protection
as competition.
Think about it as learning
the skill sets of destruction,
which are very
straightforward and simple,
and achievable for
everybody in the room.
If we compete, we're
talking about athleticism.
We're talking about years
of training, tactics.
But let's talk about what
makes competition work
in the combat sport
arena that we all kind of
hold up as the ultimate.
In order for competition
to have violence,
a competition of violence,
we have to take away what?
Injury to the human body.
In order to gamify violence,
you have to take it out.
If you look at the Ultimate
Fighting Championship, which
is kind of the premier
MMA event, you look at it,
last time I looked at
it, there were 31 rules.
27 of those rules outlawed
injury to the human body,
and rightfully so, because
there's no place for it.
You know, to deliberately
maim, cripple, or kill
your opponent is not the
game in combat sports.
Yet when you put injury
back into the equation, all
of the sudden, that puts
everybody on equal footing,
because injury bypasses
bigger, faster, stronger.
My career, what got
me into this early on
was I was training
as a young boy--
I'm a Navy brat, and I wanted
to be in the SEAL teams.
That's all I wanted to do.
And this was before the
SEALs became the big group
that they are now.
But in the early '80s,
I went through training.
I was bigger, faster, stronger.
I was the number
one guy in my class.
I was a couple weeks
away from graduation.
I already knew the
team I was going to,
which was the best
team at the time.
I did a no big deal dive that we
had to do right before the end.
I felt an underwater
wave hit my ear.
Burst my eardrum, came out,
fluid came out of my ear.
And that's the last
thing I remember,
because then I lost all sense
of sensation of balance.
I was in vertigo underwater.
This was the first
time in my life
that I had ever experienced
true injury to the human body
where my brain basically
betrays my body,
and I have no control over it.
I was able to get up.
They got me to the
surface and I was there.
But my career was
over before it even
started, because I was no
longer going to be able to dive.
My ears were ruined
at that point.
That set me on a
path that I realized
the more I looked into
injury to the human body,
we're all susceptible
to these things.
You know, any one
of us can do this.
And it didn't matter that I was
bigger, faster, and stronger.
It didn't matter
that I had will.
We don't ever want to
rely on will, you know?
And what was really
interesting is
when you apply these
similarities, when
you sit there and
look at the human body
and you realize, this
individual is just
as susceptible to
injury as I am and we
start focusing on that,
the brain's really
good at that type of training.
It's a very different mode.
If you tell yourself,
I'm helpless, you are.
But I'll challenge
that, because I've
trained people with far
more physical disability.
I'm looking at everybody
in the room right now.
I've trained people with
amazing physical disabilities,
challenges, and they've
been able to use the tool
to protect themselves.
As long as you can
think and move,
you have the ability
to protect yourself.
And the way you think
of it is a predator
will give you an
opportunity, and now you
will have some
information on how
to exploit that opportunity.
So it's not a
competition, you know?
I look at it like
competition is like taking
a huge block of marble
and saying to you, OK.
Here's your chisels.
I want you to create
"David" for me.
Michelangelo's "David" for me.
Well, very few of
us could do that.
But if I put sledgehammers
in the room and said,
you're not going to get
lunch until this thing's
a bunch of rubble, we'd all
be able to achieve that,
because why?
Destruction takes no skill set.
You know, you just
have to do it.
And the other thing that
we all have to understand
is we're all hardwired to
be really good at using
the tool of violence.
That was the one
thing in the book
that I really
wanted to point out
was that the reason we're here
is because we are the best
species in using the tool of
violence to protect ourselves,
you know?
That's number one.
Now that does not mean
we're inherently violent.
It just means from
a survival standard,
we were able to evolve.
And the most interesting
part about that is we
are not the biggest, fastest,
and strongest species.
And I say that all the
time, especially when
I'm training a lot of the
alpha operators, you know?
A lot of counterterrorist
guys that I train
and the Special Operations guys.
A lot of egos in the room.
And oftentimes I ask, OK.
Who wants to volunteer?
I've got a 10' by 10' cage.
I've got a 65-pound
mountain lion that
hasn't eaten in three
days, and I need you
to go five minutes with him.
Any takers?
You know, no.
Because why?
That's not what
makes us dangerous.
What makes us
dangerous is our brain.
The human brain is the
ultimate concealed carry.
You're seeing that
when something happens
like what happened in Vegas--
I'm from Vegas, by the way.
My wife actually is a
captain with Las Vegas Metro.
She ran the incident
scene for that.
So I have first-hand knowledge
of a horrible situation
that we all experienced.
But the problem is that when
we look at an act like that,
we often ask the
wrong questions.
We want to know,
what was he thinking?
Why was he doing this?
You know, we don't
want to believe
that there are
individuals out there that
are able and capable to
do violence like this.
And we want to think
that there's some way you
could have prevented this.
Or we want to outlaw
the tool that was used.
And this is not a
gun control debate.
What I'm trying to
tell you is I've
been in areas of the world--
I travel internationally--
where there
are the most severe penalties
for having any sort of weapon
on them.
And yet the proliferation
of weapons is just huge.
The human mind will
find a way to do it.
And that's what
makes us dangerous.
You know, the tool
itself, like I just
showed you with the knife
to the side of the neck,
is not the problem.
It's the intent that
we're doing that.
Now we flip that.
The reason I come out and
talk to people like this
is because there's a
perception that a lot of people
think you have to be some
sort of a special individual
to be able to protect
yourself physically,
and nothing could be
further from the truth.
If you want to become
a combat athlete, yes.
That's a completely
different skill set.
And that's reserved for
the physically elite.
My days of being able to compete
in the combat sport world
are long gone.
You know?
I don't want to deal with that.
I have a lot of friends.
I'm from Vegas.
I know a lot of the UFC guys.
They're amazing competitors.
But out on the street,
everything's 50/50.
It really comes down to that.
It's whoever can get the
first injury on a human being.
Now you'd ask yourself, OK, Tim.
I really don't want to train.
This really is uncomfortable.
Why would I ever want
to physically put myself
in a situation like
this and do training
for my own self-protection?
The reason you want to consider
it in some way, shape, or form
is because what it
inculcates in you
is behavior modification on
how you act in the real world.
And that's the real thing.
Because if you know what
the ramifications are,
if you know that if I ignore
my situational awareness,
if I choose to take that dicey
road at night because it's
going to save me 10 minutes
and I've got away with it,
nothing's really happened yet.
But when you know that if you're
in a situation when you're
devoid of choice,
here's the tool that's
going to get you out of here.
Here's what you're going to have
to do physically to somebody
to save your own life.
The behavior
modification is huge.
Most people that I come across
with in some part of their life
are doing the
equivalent of sleeping
with their head on
a railroad track.
And they're betting
the fact that the train
didn't come last night,
that it's not going to come.
My goal in teaching somebody
how to use the tool of violence
is that's going to
allow them to finally
take their head off
the railroad track
so the potentiality for
violence is minimized.
Because that's my real goal.
My real goal is
not to teach people
how to use the tool of violence.
It is a necessary thing.
I think everybody should
understand how to do this,
just like everybody
understands how to swim.
How many people in
here know how to swim?
OK.
Now did you parents, when
they originally had you swim
or when you took it upon
yourself to learn swimming,
was it because you wanted
to become Michael Phelps?
No.
It's because you
don't want to drown.
That's the same
thing when it looks
to your own self-protection.
You should have some basic
knowledge of the tool.
And you know, knowing it
doesn't bring it upon you.
There are people that think if
they look at this information
that somehow they'll
either become criminal,
which is not true--
you're not going
to break your own moral code.
And they also think, oh, well,
maybe it'll bring it upon me.
There's that whole idea.
If I focus on violence, violence
is going to come find me.
And I understand, that's
kind of the karmic thing
that people talk about.
My argument to that
is, do you have a--
most places have
a code where you
have to have a fire
extinguisher in your kitchen.
Does that mean you're
looking for a fire?
Does that mean that
you're bringing a bigger
chance of fire into your life?
No.
Actually what
happens is you end up
living a much more
peaceful life.
Because just like the fact that
you don't worry about a kitchen
fire because you say, OK,
I've already understood.
I got the thing.
I know I can get
out of the house.
I've already looked at that.
I know how to operate
the fire extinguisher.
You then go on to
live your life.
You cook, you have a great
time, you don't worry about it.
Same thing in self-protection.
When you've learned
the basics, you
understand how the
tool of violence works,
you understand why things
happen, you change on
how you do-- you make much
better decisions in your life.
And you get yourself
out of problems.
Because a lot of times
what happens is we
participate in things that we
don't have to participate in.
You know, you will
sit there, after you
learn about the
tool of violence,
you're not going to take
the bait on the road rage.
You're not going to take
the bait at the bar.
You know, a lot of people
will show this information.
They'll show it in
a bar fight format.
Like, I have people in my
industry basically teaching you
how to win a bar fight,
which is basically also
how to win a jail cell.
You know, which is that.
It's showing the
absolute wrong context.
And the majority
of you, if you were
shown how to win
a bar fight, you'd
ignore all that information.
And rightfully so,
meaning because it's
showing the wrong context.
But there's probably some
good information in there.
They've just shown it in
a way that's criminal,
and we inherently know that.
Therefore, we dismiss even
looking at the information,
and that's the problem.
My whole goal is really what
I said at the beginning.
I have a narrow
definition of when
we'd ever use the
tool of violence,
and really, it's
devoid of choice.
It's you are facing imminent
grievous bodily harm,
and there's no exit, and there's
no communication going on.
It's a very narrow window.
It's the same window that
if you had a firearm on you,
you would feel
justified in emptying
the firearm into that threat.
That is the threshold on
when you'd ever use the tool.
So people say from
a legal standpoint,
if you're asking
legal questions,
it's probably not the time
you use the tool of violence.
If you want to shut
the loud mouth up
or if your ego's been
done or somebody's
being inappropriate--
and I'll give you
a perfect example,
because I'm not immune to this.
My son now is 21.
My oldest son is 21.
I picked him up at
about 10 years ago.
10 years ago, I pick him up.
And I go to take him--
I had a seminar that I
was training that day.
I was going to drop him
off with my brother.
He was going to go hang out
with my brother for a while.
We were going to have a
great dinner that night.
I pull out.
Nobody's on the road.
This guy comes barreling
down and somehow
thinks I got in his lane.
Like, I tried to cut
him off or something.
So he's steaming.
He was really mad.
And he's, you know, flipping
me off, doing everything.
And I just kind of let it go.
Well, of course,
there's a light.
You know, he's stopped.
I have to pull up next to him.
And that's when it starts.
Oh, look at you.
Yeah, you think you're
so tough, tough guy?
And I'm like, my what?
Eight-year-old son is
sitting right there
that he's yelling
through, and he's
calling me all sorts of names.
I Have a tattoo.
He says, oh, look.
You think you're a tough guy.
You've got this tattoo.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
He's baiting me,
baiting me, baiting me.
And I could just tell, he was
just a really annoyed guy.
And it was embarrassing
to have my son hear me.
What was more
embarrassing was my son
having to be holding
"Black Belt" magazine,
of which I was on the cover.
[LAUGHTER]
You know?
And to eight-year-old
boy, he's like, God.
You should have-- you could
have got out there and taken
care of him.
Don't let anybody
talk to you like that.
And I said, you're right, son.
I probably could
have got out there,
and there's a good chance that
I would have done pretty well.
I said, but I had the choice.
I had the choice not to.
What I didn't tell him, because
he was young at that time,
is yeah, I had to
also think, OK.
So I'm successful.
What if I get arrested?
You know?
Because I chose to
participate in that.
What if he got me.
What if I didn't know he
had a weapon or something,
and I'm killed in
front of my son?
You know, the ramifications
of all those things.
The only reason I was
able to make that decision
is because I had thought
about it ahead of time,
and I understood
the ramifications
of using the tool.
If I have a choice, I never
want to flip that coin,
because that coin is
always a 50/50, you know?
So it's very rare.
So living in that world, I'm
a very calm person that way.
I want to be the
friendliest person there is.
People meet me, they go,
God, you're such a nice guy.
And when I do that, I go, good.
I got you.
I want people to
think I'm a nice guy.
I don't want them to
think there's anything--
because if I need
the tool of violence,
I want it to be a total
surprise that I can use it.
And I don't mean that
from a paranoid sense,
but I want to operate
that way, you know?
And I understand.
I understand there
are times where
we-- most of the time when you
want to respond with violence,
it's the wrong time.
Most of the time when
you want to communicate,
it's the wrong time.
And what do I mean by that?
Guy spills a drink on
you, is kind of obnoxious.
Oh, you want to respond.
You want to go in there.
You want to start escalating.
In the middle of
the night, your door
gets kicked in in your bedroom.
Guy in a balaclava
and a shotgun,
and two other guys
with duct tape.
What do you want to do?
Who are you?
Why are you here?
You know, it's
like, probably not--
[LAUGHTER]
--probably not the right time to
use that information, you know?
And so my goal in all of this
is just to, by looking at this
and by going through
the book, you'll
have a very good
understanding of how
violence fits into
our society, The fact
that this is something that--
the most uncomfortable
thing for most people
is not the fact of
learning the tool.
It's when they go
through it, it's
finding out that they're
already really good at this.
They already know
how to use the tool,
and it's a little bit
uncomfortable for most of us,
because we haven't had access
to that for a long time.
By passing on this type of
information, we could have--
probably the one thing I
would probably leave you
with before there might be
any questions is the most
interesting thing is
when I trained originally
in the military and the
law enforcement arenas
and we did it in all the Special
Operations area, what we found
was there were less incidences--
in the military sense,
there were less incidences
of liberty risk.
We used to call them.
Guys going out and getting in
fights on their off-time duty.
In the law enforcement
world, there
was a drop in
excessive use of force.
And what we found is the
more highly trained somebody
is in a lethal application of
violence, the calmer they are.
It's the exact paradox of
what you'd think it would be.
By understanding
violence, you actually
end up living a much
more peaceful life.
And I found that.
The most capable
individuals that I
happen to know that
are in this world
are extremely calm
individuals, and really
go out of their way--
and I'm saying the people
that participate in society, not
the people that we incarcerate.
But the people that
participate in society
that have a very good
understanding of the tool
don't misuse it.
They understand when it
would ever be appropriate.
And until that time, they
are focused completely
on having a great life.
And that's really what
I wish for everybody
that I come in contact with.
My sincere hope is
that when people come,
seek out training,
or do that that I
hope the information remains
completely useless to them
the rest of their life.
I hope they get
to live that life.
But should it come, I want
to be like that doctor,
that unlikely individual that
all of the sudden his brain
says, OK.
This isn't the first time
I've thought about this.
Now I know what to look for.
I know there are
opportunities for me.
How do I focus on
my opportunities?
And that's probably the
biggest change that you can do.
But it starts with
looking at the subject.
And you know, merely
listening to this talk today
alone has really helped
open that up for you guys.
And I hope maybe it'll
pursue reading the book
and asking yourself
the right questions.
What are you doing in
your life right now
out of convenience that
is putting you at risk?
And there's probably a
lot of things, you know?
And I have a story for every
one of those, unfortunately.
But you can internally
do that yourself.
But this has been an
opportunity for me
to share with you why
I wrote this book.
This book is probably 20 years.
This is the book that
I've been wanting
to write for quite
some time, because I
think it's a timely
subject, unfortunately.
And we're not going to go away.
And what you're seeing
also is you're seeing
what's really scaring people--
yeah, Vegas was
a horrible event,
but that was using firearms.
But the more scary
thing for people
are the people using
vehicles, people running out
just using table knives, using
machetes, things like that.
Readily available, low tech,
you know, violence basically.
And it's becoming
[INAUDIBLE],, because you
can't outlaw intent.
You can't outlaw
the human brain,
and the human brain
will find that.
One of the terrorism
experts that
was interviewed on
one of the things,
the night of the
Nice truck bombing
or the Nice truck
attacks that came in,
it hit him all at once.
And he said something
that I've been
saying for quite some time,
which was, we're finally here.
We're up against the opponent
that we can't predict
and we can't defeat, and
that's the human mind.
When a human has the
will to do something,
they're going to do it.
And that's why you want to have
a base understanding of how
this tool works so you
don't have irrational fear.
My whole goal is not that you
don't have fear or trepidation.
I don't want you to freeze.
You know?
And by understanding the tool
of violence, you don't get that.
You know?
You sit there.
You're not surprised by
an event like in Vegas.
You understand it.
You know, you're
saddened by it, but you
understand the potentiality
for things like that.
You look at it.
What I want to leave
you with is a quick way
to start changing the
way you look at violence,
and it's going to
be a challenge.
For the next 30 days, when
you see an act of violence
in the news, when you
see an act of violence
on TV, the internet, and
unfortunately-- fortunately
for me because it's instructive,
there's a lot out there.
But if you're looking
like a closed circuit TV,
I want you to look at
the act of violence,
and I want you to do what
these alpha predators do,
because it was really-- this
was probably most jarring thing
that I saw when I was
interviewing these guys.
When they see an
act of violence,
they look at-- they
never see themselves
from the victim's perspective.
So where you and I would see an
act of violence and we'd say,
oh my God.
Look at what
happened to that guy.
Oh, I wonder if we
could have done this,
and we're trying
to work our way out
of the other side
of the equation,
they only identify
with the winning side
of the use of the
tool of violence.
OK?
The alpha alphas look at that,
and they not only look at it
from the winning side.
They then try to
improve upon it.
They'll say, yeah,
that was good,
but I would have
done it this way.
Now we think by
doing that that, oh,
we're condoning criminal acts.
Because maybe the victim,
it was a criminal act.
What you're really
doing, though,
is we are not going to condone--
I'm not asking you to
do this and say, yeah,
we're condoning
the criminal act.
What I want you to do
is inoculate your brain
and understand there's
nothing to learn
from the victim's perspective.
There's no useful information
What is useful to you is when
you see an act of violence
is asking yourself the
question, when did everything
change in the winner's favor?
Whoever ended up winning
in that act of violence?
I know that's a
horrible thing to talk
about when you're looking at a
murder or something like that.
But if you watch
it, there's going
to be a point where something
happened to the other person,
and then it just
went from there.
And that something usually
is injury to the human body.
Some part of the human
body got a big result,
and that's the
useful information.
When you see things
in prison yards,
if you ever see a prison fight
that's out there like maybe
on the news or
something like that,
it's interesting to watch
the act of violence.
Far more interesting to
watch everybody around.
They're like this and they're
looking the whole time,
because they want to know where
the useful information is.
So my goal to you,
my challenge to you
is a 30-day challenge of
looking at the tool of violence.
Ask yourself, when did it change
in the other person's favor?
And then in about 10 days--
I'll give you 10 days
to get used to that--
in 10 days start
asking yourself,
how would I improve upon it?
How could I have
done that better?
And what you start doing is
you start telling your brain,
I only identify with the
successful use of the tool.
And this works with
every mental training
program that's out there
as far as visualization.
If you're a golfer,
you don't ever
imagine, OK, I go from
the tee to the rough,
from the rough to the beach,
three strikes on the beach,
get up on the green, and
I do a four putt, OK?
Which is essentially
what you're doing
when you're looking at things
from the victim's perspective.
No.
What do you imagine
if you're a golfer?
You go tee to fairway,
fairway to green, one to two
putt, whatever is realistic
for you at that point.
But that's what you start
putting in your head.
And there's nothing wrong
with you doing the same thing
when it comes to the
pull of violence.
Asking yourself, where's
the positive information?
It is uncomfortable for
the first couple of days.
After a while, you feel
almost like a coroner.
A coroner will look
at a murder victim
and will have empathy
for the murder victim.
But once he or she
starts the report,
it's very clinical
and straightforward.
And that's what you
need to do when you're
looking at an act of violence.
I want you to
protect your brain.
And that's probably
the big thing.
I just want you
to understand, you
don't need to give
up your empathy.
You'll have that.
But if you really want
to make a quick change,
just start doing this.
So I would love to hear--
I have an experiment going
on right now with the book--
I would love to hear your
response to that, you know?
I'm having guys
right now that are
in the middle of the 30-day.
Within four days,
they're noticing changes
in how they look at the subject.
Now the last thing.
If you go to
whenviolenceistheanswer.com,
everybody that's here,
I do a 10-module--
there's 10 chapters in the book.
I have 10 videos that I've
done that are available to you
for free--
there's no cost
to it-- where I go
in-depth on each one of these.
And it's a really good program,
and I think you'll like it.
I can't thank everybody enough
for having me here today.
I'm totally available
for any questions.
But this was a
really great chance
to come out and
share the message.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE] so guys,
we have a couple minutes left.
Does anyone have any
questions or comments
you want to throw Tim's way?
Going once.
Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
So we'll start over here.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I have a question about the
30-day challenge you just
mentioned.
You said somebody will
come and give you feedback
that they have.
They see some changes in
their life or their mind.
Could you just share what
kind of change they have?
TIM LARKIN: Yeah.
Most people, the
change that they
have when doing what
I just asked you to do
is all of a sudden they
start operating differently.
They start seeing themselves
as able to actually act
in proactive violence.
Be proactive in violence.
Rather than be defensive
and wait for things
to happen to them,
they're immediately
looking at opportunities.
It flips the brain that way.
We call it-- in the book,
I call it cause state.
It's worked with traders.
Like, I've trained a lot of the
traders in the financial world.
And you don't want to
be in the effect state.
When you're in the
effect state, which
is you're trying
to react to what's
already been done to you, you're
way behind the power curve.
In a life or death
situation, it's critical.
You know, you want
to be in cause state
and you want to be in control.
In a business
sense, you know, it
can be costly for you to
always be in the effect state.
So the mindset is there.
And in violence, the
best way to do it
is to start identifying with,
OK, what works in violence,
you know?
The traders took
that information
and said, well, nothing happens
till I execute the trade.
So instead of just being
in paralysis by analysis,
they understood they
had to make decisions
and they had to
execute, and then
they had to judge off of
that, judging off of action.
The premise works in a
lot of different areas
that are not
life-threatening, but
in your life-threatening
situation,
if somebody grabs
you around the neck,
I want your first thought
to be, oh, thank God.
I know where his hands are.
What do I have?
And you immediately
transfer-- you
ignore this being done to you,
because you can't undo this.
But what I can do
is say, oh, look.
There's his throat.
There's his eye.
This is all available to
me, because you've trained
your brain to react that way.
And this is the first
thing that saves people.
I've had have numerous
accounts of people
that have trained with us that
they get into this situation.
The first thing
they saw, you know,
they saw that one square inch
of the human body that they knew
would get a result, and
that's what they did.
They immediately
attacked, because they
were trained that way,
rather than trying
to undo what was being
done to them at the time.
And you'll find the people that
survive in violent situations
are the people that respond
by injuring the other person,
not trying to keep themselves
from being stabbed, from being
hit, from being punched.
It's a much more difficult
equation, you know?
So that's how you start.
But it starts up
here with the brain.
I can teach you all the physical
movements and all the punching
and kicking.
If I can't get your brain
to operate correctly,
it's never going
to work for you.
So that's why drills
like this are really very
straightforward and simple.
And these are probably some
of the biggest game changes
that people have when they
start looking at this subject.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TIM LARKIN: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
I think the biggest barrier for
people, the way I perceive it,
is the fact that these
criminals, for instance, they
are clearly, most of
them, psychopaths, right?
They don't have this mechanism
that keeps most of us
back from engaging in violence,
because our brain basically
says, you know,
thou shall not do,
you know, intentional
harm to somebody else.
And I think the reason it
could be difficult to engage
in your 30-day challenge is
because of this reaction from
the brain that says, I
cannot identify myself with
a psychopath that does things
like that, and therefore,
I'm not going to think that way.
So do you have a
solution to that?
TIM LARKIN: Yeah.
You basically have people
like turn the audio off,
and they clinically-- we
get caught up in the story.
You remember, when I was telling
you about the young woman being
attacked by the guy and a
knife to the side of the neck,
you probably were all
caught up in the story.
You know, what you
need to focus on
was the knife to the
side of the neck.
And that's the difference.
I get it.
We all want the story.
Right now, what's
the biggest thing
people want in the
Vegas shooting?
A story.
They wonder, why
was he doing this?
Does it matter?
It really doesn't.
There's nothing to learn.
You know, they're
analyzing his brain.
They're going to do
all these other things.
That's not where the
good information is.
And it's hard for
us, and the reason
I give you this
30-day challenge is
because you're going to be
amazed that after three or four
days of this that you
don't feel like a criminal.
You don't feel aggressive.
You don't feel
anything like that.
But your brain-- you're
giving your brain direction
to look at things
differently and go, oh, OK.
That worked.
That was-- that's
actually good information.
Oh, look.
He got a huge
result out of that.
Oh.
And I've challenged people
with some really hard things
to look at.
But again, you're not
condoning the act.
What you do is you're
inoculating your brain
from looking at the
losing side of violence.
And that's the most important
thing for our self-protection.
We can empathize
with the victim,
but if we look at things from
the victim's perspective,
we're actually putting
ourselves at risk that way.
And so that's the whole
idea of the exercise.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned the
sleepwalking through life
and having a head
on the train tracks.
And thank you for the
talk, because I'm already
starting to think about
just some simple things I
do that I'll do
differently moving forward.
Curious if you identified
one or a handful of the most
common things that people
are kind of oblivious to
in their everyday life.
TIM LARKIN: Yeah.
The number one thing is
obviously our obsession
with our smartphones.
And what I mean by that
is what we're doing
is we're depriving
ourselves-- what
we saw on the bus is
we, on a regular basis,
are depriving ourselves
of our sensory systems.
My vision is myopic.
It's focused here.
And oftentimes, I've
also hijacked my hearing.
And you tell people, like, the
other thing that you have to do
is people say, well, I should
be able to do X, Y, or Z.
And yes, in a perfect
world, you should.
I should be able to
live in a neighborhood
where I don't have to
lock my doors, but I do.
You know?
And so it's this
idea of, it's my job
to sit there and
tell people, listen.
I get it.
You want to be able to
jog and listen to this,
and you want to be able
to jog at 10:30 at night.
Precipitously, you know, I
show this one video of an ATM--
these old people
going to an ATM.
And they sit there.
And I show it.
And I showed it to a bunch
of self-defense experts also.
And everybody's
saying, well-- and this
was an old guy that was
hobbling up and his wife, right?
Well, the old guy should have
been turning around and facing
this way so he would have
seen the attackers coming,
and then they come up
with all these scenarios.
Nobody looked at the time code.
It was 10:30 at night.
What was so important that
they had to get cash out
at 10:30 at night that
they couldn't have got up
20 minutes earlier in the
morning when the risk is
precipitously lower?
How many times had they done
that and got away with it?
You know, they're probably
almost even arrogant about it.
I should be able to do
it in this neighborhood.
And they were just there and
the predators were there,
and they saw the [INAUDIBLE].
So simple things.
You know, I don't want to
show an older gentleman how
to deal with three
raging attackers
when all I have to tell
him is, don't do it.
Just don't do it.
And your risk is going
to go precipitously down.
And that's the
hard part of this.
I show the physical aspect
of it because I have to,
but it is the last resort.
And I'll tell you
what's most important.
The people that have had to
use the physical for the most
part and the people that
come to me that are that 70%
that violence has
already happened to them,
I will tell you each and every
time, it's this one thing.
At this point, I felt
something was wrong.
But because it would have
been socially awkward
for me to either leave or do
something, I kept with it.
And then by the time
this started happening,
it was already too late.
I was already in it.
So I will tell you,
we have thousands
of years of evolution
of nonverbal cues
that are in our body,
and do not ignore those.
Risk being socially awkward.
Guy gets into the
elevator and pulls--
women are amazing this way.
Women have far more of an
awareness of the potentiality
for violence than men do.
I did a thing recently
with Tony Robbins.
It was at one of his events.
And he asked before
I started training,
he asked everybody in the
room, he goes, hey, I'm
not saying it happened,
anything happened to you,
but the last three
days, how many of you
have felt potentiality
for violence?
Maybe 5% of the men [INAUDIBLE].
Well over 95% of the
women raised their hands.
And it was just an awareness of
a strange guy walked this way.
Women are extremely
aware of that.
So don't not--
don't ignore that.
That is probably our
number one thing.
Because I'm the one that deals
with it on the other end of it,
because I'm the one that has
to hear the story about how
you did ignore it, and then
you didn't have the skill
sets to deal with it physically.
You know?
And So that's probably
my biggest thing.
And what's interesting is the
more you look at the tool,
the more you look at
these acts of violence,
train your brain to do
this, you automatically
just start making
better decisions.
You know?
We're actually
really-- we're not
looking to engage in violence.
And the other thing
that's interesting
is your situational
awareness, by raising it up,
you're far less
likely to be chosen.
Predators don't
want a challenge.
They don't want to
go against somebody
who's situationally aware.
They want to go against somebody
who's lost in their phone,
not paying attention.
And so my goal with my clients
is not to eradicate violence.
That's Criminal violence
is going to be there.
I just want my people
to get the pass.
I want my people to have
enough skill sets in them
that they just don't
look like an easy victim.
And that's really
what it's all about.
Did that answer--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, for sure.
Thank you.
TIM LARKIN: OK.
AUDIENCE: That was incredible.
One of the best talks
I've heard in a while.
I liked the analogies of the
fire hydrant and the train
track.
But my question to you right
now is, as I'm sitting here
and we mentioned the Vegas
shooting a couple times,
and I'm trying to do that
exercise that you challenge
us to, if we could just--
maybe it's a little too
sensitive, but maybe not.
Can we just walk
through that together?
So would it be in the eyes
of the attacker in his room?
Would it then be what
could he have done better,
or how could he have
harmed more people?
TIM LARKIN: Yeah.
In that particular environment--
OK, just to be very
brutally honest with it,
you know, it could have
been a whole lot worse
with what he had up there.
He actually-- we're really
lucky that he wasn't
able to use all of the
ammunition that he had up there
and utilized all of the guns.
So that perspective.
When you look at the numbers
of rounds shot and the people
killed, you say, oh, OK, well,
he wasn't that good, you know?
I mean, that's a hard--
do you see how--
you're all probably struggling
with what I just said, OK?
And I understand that.
But I'm putting my head--
you know, OK.
Using the act of violence,
using a tool like that,
this is what--
and what this does is it takes
all of the irrational fear
away from us, OK?
I know if I was
there-- and by the way,
I was scheduled to be there.
Tony Robbins basically
probably saved me
from being shot, because I
was doing his event in Maui,
and I gave my Route
91 tickets away.
My wife and I gave them away.
And we were both going
to go to the event.
and that's when it all happened.
Like I said, she ended up
being incident commander.
Had I been there, you're
in an open-- and guys,
it's a blank parking lot.
There is no cover anywhere, OK?
I could accept that, though.
Meaning when I look at
all this I realize, OK.
A lot of people that
have been trained
have been in
situations where there
was nothing they could do.
And the good part about that
is they actually knew that.
A lot of people really
just wrack their brains.
They survive situations.
And they think, because they
don't understand the tool,
they think, well, maybe
there was something I could
have done, and they just--
they guilt themselves.
When you understand
the tool of violence,
you also understand
when you're screwed.
You understand
when, hey, there's
nothing I can
potentially do here.
And you're OK with it.
I had one of my guys that
became an instructor later on.
He was a manager at
a restaurant when he
was going through grad school.
Takes the trash out
with his busboy,
comes back to a
guy with a shotgun.
His first thought, the way
the guy's holding the shotgun,
I can take him.
He has no idea of the angle.
I can go in and I can take him.
But I'd better wait,
because I've got to see.
I've got my whole
staff in there.
I've got to see what's going on.
Goes in there, and sure enough.
Four more guys with shotguns,
staff all on the ground, prone.
He gets down prone
on the ground, OK?
Realizes there's nothing to do.
They comply with everything.
Here's the difference.
Because he had been
training in this
and because he'd been
doing some of the things
I'm asking you to
do, of the 30 people
on staff that were
in that restaurant,
prone on the ground,
he was the only one
that didn't need psychological
counseling after.
And he was the only one that
could identify the shooters,
point them out in court down
to the identifying tattoos
on these individuals.
Why?
Because he never gave up.
He was constantly looking.
Really, there's
nothing I can do.
Yes, I can take this
guy, but I'm not
going to risk my people.
And he was OK with that.
And that's the idea behind it.
So I just want to
give you an example.
I don't want you to think that
we turn into these super ninjas
and we always do things.
No.
But we're constantly
aware of our surroundings.
We're aware of the situation.
Understand how violence works.
This particular situation,
too much of a risk.
Not worth it.
You know?
And that's the value of it.
That's the value of
looking at the subject.
It does not make you
paranoid, I guarantee you.
It doesn't make
you one of these,
like, these prepper
type of guys that
go around totally paranoid all
the time and backs to the wall.
That's not what I want.
What I want you to do is
just to understand that, hey.
This is how physical
violence works.
This is how they take
advantage of you.
This is how predators
look at you.
And oh, by the way, they're
just as susceptible to this as
possible.
And the example I
give on that is, OK.
I have a fire gun.
That guy that had the
gun in the video, OK?
If the bus was going 50 miles
an hour into a concrete pylon,
does that give
him any protection
from physical violence, what
happens when that bus hits?
Is he going to be
any better protected
that anybody else on there
that doesn't have a gun?
No.
The only reason that
works is because he
can operate the tool.
But as soon as you
injure him, he's
not going to be able to operate
the tool anymore at that point.
And I show people, and
I show examples of that,
people using firearms on people
and also them being injured,
and they can no longer operate
the firearm at that point.
The firearm itself doesn't
give any inherent power.
My 25 years plus
of being a master
close combat instructor,
training Tier 1 groups,
all of these other
groups I've trained,
amazing people all around
the world, agencies
you probably haven't
heard of, and soccer moms.
Really great people.
All that experience, I walk
right out the door here,
I catch a pipe to
the back of the head,
I go down just like
everybody else.
My training doesn't
inoculate me.
But I accept that.
I understand that I'm human, and
this works just as well on me.
And that's the beauty
of it, you know?
When we understand it like
that, we can take a Vegas event
and we can make sense of it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: One more
question here.
So you're talking about all
of the response when there's
basically no plan B anymore.
So I'm curious about,
either is training
available to deal
with, I would say,
medium threatening situations?
For example, is it
like something is--
the reason came up
with this question
is if something were
to happen to me when
I came to work
this morning, there
was a man sitting before me
who was making a pot in a bus.
And the kids [INAUDIBLE] start
talking some nonsense to me.
So in that case, you
know, for me, there was--
a little bit threatening.
He's apparently
high to an extent.
How should people respond?
From even after the talk today,
I was [INAUDIBLE] for OK,
is there a way we can
avert the situation?
You know, just avoid it
as opposed to fight it.
So just either
training specifically
to deal with this medium
threatening situation where you
still have a chance to make a--
TIM LARKIN: Yeah.
When you're talking about an
individual who's probably high
or on some sort of a heightened
substance or something
like that, you're
not going to be
able to rationalize with them.
And when you're in a closed
environment like that,
you know, it's kind of rare.
But it still meets
that threshold.
When there's still
communication going on,
it's still-- it's
anti-social aggression.
We haven't really
talked about that.
Anti-social aggression
versus asocial violence.
Asocial violence is
he's not talking at you.
He just literally comes down
and attacks you right away.
That's the imminent--
you know, now
we know that I need to respond
with the tool of violence
to protect myself.
What you're talking about is
that uncomfortable situation
where you don't
really have an exit,
but it's still
anti-social aggression.
So you have to monitor it, and
you have to make that decision.
At any time if you feel
threatened, you know,
really physically
threatened for your body,
you may have to use
the tool of violence.
You may have to
respond with violence.
But it will always be--
it'll be a question.
You know, I don't know
what your threshold is,
where you feel-- you
know, my threshold
might be different than
yours and different than his,
you know?
We all have this
personal threshold.
And so you have to understand.
Oftentimes what
you're wrestling with
is the idea that it was
really, really annoying,
and you really wanted
to do something,
and you weren't able to because
it wasn't the right time.
What I can tell everybody
is once you cross
that physical plane and you
put your hands on somebody,
you have no idea where
it's going to end up.
And that's the one
thing-- you have to be OK.
You have to be OK
with the fact that you
could end up killing a person or
they could end up killing you.
And then I talk
about in the book
this idea of the
three-day test, the event
that you're responding to.
Well, this event
that just happened,
you're living your life right
now, three days from now,
will it matter to you?
AUDIENCE: Probably not.
TIM LARKIN: Exactly.
And that's the idea.
I mean, when you're asking me--
what I ask my clients to do
is the event that bothers them
that they're talking about,
three days from now if you're
sitting in a jail cell
or you're six feet under,
will you look at the situation
and say, you know what?
There's nothing I could do.
I had to respond that way.
Very few things
meet that threshold.
And this is how I'm saying
the behavioral change.
You're still going
to feel annoyed.
How do you think I felt
when I was being humiliated
by this guy who I probably
could have just destroyed
in front of my son?
You know?
Oh, by the way, I forgot to
tell you the last part of that.
I was going to train my seminar.
That's how I opened
up my seminar.
I want you to understand,
I understand, guys.
It just happened to me.
And I put that in,
because I felt--
even with all my training,
I still feel like, oh, God.
It would have been
good to respond.
ego-justifying just
to respond so my son could
sit there and say, wow.
Dad, that was great, you know?
And then I'm thinking
about that going, really?
I want my son to see me
beating down on somebody?
You know, it's these things
that we get caught up in.
But recognizing that.
This is a situation where you
felt probably a little bit
like should have taken action.
You might have felt like the
guy was invading your space
and threatening
you, and that you
need to respond to the threat.
But it didn't reach
that threshold,
and you've got to
be OK with that.
I have to be OK with
being called names.
my ego being bruised.
I have to be OK
with looking weak.
I give myself that
permission to do that.
As soon as it crosses
the point where
it's imminent danger and
it's grievous bodily harm,
I'm the first one
to take action.
But until it gets
to that point, I'm
not going to pull that trigger.
You know, it's just my
personal way of doing it.
Now there are a lot of
people in my industry
that will talk about bar fights.
They'll talk about all
this ridiculous stuff.
And I'm just telling you
right now, any of that stuff
will literally-- it's
just a ticket to dealing
with the legal system.
It's just never
worth it, you know?
And I'm shocked at some
of the guys that actually
propose that kind of stuff.
You know, that's
why-- how this says,
a very narrow
definition of violence
will save you wear and tear.
It may even save your life.
And that's it.
You've got to have that narrow
definition of when you'd ever
do it.
The de-escalation that
you're talking about,
it's a verbal technique.
There are a lot of
groups out there
that'll teach you verbal
engagement, de-escalation,
anger management, all
those types of things.
And those may be good
things for you to employ.
But as far as the tool of
violence, unfortunately,
we have this really narrow
window when we ever, ever
want to use it and
still stay citizens,
so we still stay productive
citizens that way.
I know it's not the answer you
wanted, but I hope it helped.
AUDIENCE: Actually, just--
TIM LARKIN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I just got a
small follow-up here.
Would it ever, for example--
you know, let's say there is
a psychological threshold that
has been breached.
Would there ever be any
cases where it justifies
the preemptive action?
TIM LARKIN: Yeah.
So that's a great question.
And everybody's
justification is there.
If you feel imminent
grievous bodily
harm, if you truly feel your
life is in danger, then yes,
of course.
AUDIENCE: My question
is that even from, like,
case's perspective.
What are the odds of
taking preemptive actions?
I mean, it's one thing to think,
OK, you know, it's justified.
But in reality, it might turn
out to be the other way, right?
TIM LARKIN: The reason
I give the threshold
that I give is
because when you get
into the legal
system on something
like that, what
you're talking about,
now you're turning it
over to the legal system.
What I want to
achieve is that when
the police show up to
whatever the event is
that you're talking
about that it ends there.
That they have the interview
with you, and they feel,
great, you know?
He You were
absolutely justified,
and everybody says that.
Meaning the event that
you're talking about,
whatever you're thinking
about right now,
hopefully you have corroborating
witnesses that say, yes, he
was doing nothing.
He was trying to disengage.
This person kept coming,
kept coming, kept coming,
was verbally threatening,
was aggressively
coming and threatening
physical harm at that point,
and you were totally
justified in what you did.
And that's where
you want to end it.
But the legal system,
you have to be prepared.
If I'm going to use
the tool of violence,
I have to be prepared to
understand that I may face
legal ramifications on that.
And I have to be OK with that.
That's why it's so important
to have that definition that
works for you, when it would
ever be appropriate for you.
And the more you
look at the subject,
the easier it is to
come to that conclusion,
because you start realizing
very few things in your life
meet that threshold.
OK?
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Oh, this is cool.
So like, similar situation
where someone was threatening--
I guess my sister's
boyfriend was
threatening me and my family.
And he just got too close
to my personal space,
so I felt like I needed to
take action, which I did.
And his friends
showed up as well,
and the cops showed up as well.
But they weren't able
to differentiate me
from my sister's friends.
So I was assaulted by the
police and my sister's friends.
So in cases like
those, would you--
how would you go about handling
those sorts of things when
your family is in danger, but
then when the authorities do
show up, they end up taking out
sort of more violence on you?
Because I couldn't fight back.
TIM LARKIN: So I'm going to give
you an answer that you probably
won't like, but it's how
these guys handle it, OK?
What's really
interesting is my wife
has told me this numerous times.
And again, you know, I
understand there are bad cops.
There's all of that.
And there's no justification
for that at all.
But the reality is this.
When one of these
guys normally gets
pulled over or
anything like that,
they're completely
compliant right away.
Meaning the younger guys, the
guys coming up and all that,
they don't--
a guy like the two guys
you heard, their whole idea
is, my lawyer's going
to take care of this.
And they're hoping the cops
are going to be aggressive.
They're hoping the cops
are going to do something,
because they're two steps ahead.
They're thinking about
talking to their lawyer.
what the situation is,
and the whole thing.
So they're going
to endure whatever
they're enduring right
now, and then they're
going to let their legal
mouthpiece tell the story.
And that's the thing I
try to tell everybody.
There is never a good--
listen.
Say it isn't
authorities, you know?
Say it's third world
countries that I've done.
I've had Federales
beat the hell out of me
when I was surfing
down in Mexico, when
I was in high school, you know?
But we were compliant.
We realized the situation
for what it was.
We were able to
get out and we were
able to take care of ourselves.
There's never a value in a
situation like that for you,
unless truly your
life is in danger.
Meaning they're beating
you to the point
to where you feel like if you
don't fight back, you're dead.
Then yeah.
That's where you
would fight back.
But the best approach
that I learned--
it was really interesting.
The more I studied these
guys, the more they
absolutely look at it that way.
They look at the police as, OK.
You're just the delivery
system and the legal system,
and I've got a lawyer
that I'm going to talk to.
And that's where I'm
going to deal with what's
going on here at that point.
And whatever just
happened here, the reason
you showed up to get me, I'll
deal with these guys later.
But I'm going to let
my lawyer talk on that.
And when you make that
leap, it's empowering.
It's really empowering.
Because anything
that was unjustified,
you've done nothing in that
situation to exacerbate it.
And now you have a
really powerful stick
if you use it correctly with
the legal aspect of things.
And this is even when
using a public defender.
You can get that on there.
It's not the answer
that's right, though.
It's not the justified answer.
AUDIENCE: No, I get that.
And I get what you're saying,
like, completely be compliant.
Like, I've been in situations
where, you know, hands
on the steering wheel.
Yes, I'm willing to
comply with whatever.
They came into this
situation thinking--
because my mom is white,
so they thought we were--
I didn't really get a
chance to explain what
was happening to the police.
TIM LARKIN: They
jumped right into--
AUDIENCE: And so I'm saying if
you were able to rewind back
in time and you were
in that situation
where your family
was being threatened
on your property, what
actions would you have taken?
TIM LARKIN: I don't know.
I would have to
be in that moment.
I mean, if I truly felt--
I have to make that
decision ahead of time.
You know, if I truly
felt that people
are facing that imminent,
grievous bodily harm danger,
I'm going to be OK being in
that jail cell, you know?
It's a decision
I've already made,
but man, it's a high threshold.
It really has to be there
before I do anything like that.
And the one thing I've
learned is also verbally
not escalating with it.
You know, I get really
calm when people go.
Because the more aggravated
they get, your response there--
it's this counterintuitive
thing that you
start doing that really
works on communication.
People talk about
it all the time,
but it's really hard
to do in the moment.
And you have to train
yourself to respond that way.
You know?
But that's a great
question, you know?
SPEAKER 1: All right, guys.
Thank you so much
for coming out.
Tim.
TIM LARKIN: Thank you very much.
I really appreciate it.
I was great.
[APPLAUSE]
Good questions.